400 prêtres oxame tu entres dans nabi
rect bonjour je suis la main que l'on
soit claustrophobe ou non plongé dans
cette es3 labyrinthe peut devenir
angoissant
si roxane accepte de relever le défi
c'est qu'elle est ici pour apprendre à
mieux gérer son stress
est-ce que la secte on est assez vaste
recensement
ouais c'est à combiers surtout en garde
ok tu vois le ton visage et de rue rouge
je comptais passer pas et que j'ai là de
nestea n'est pas en train mais aussi en
hébreu
oui ça peut paraître très impressionnant
mon force jamais un jeune on lui propose
des défis et après on voit comment elle
réagit je n'attends plus tôt a créé le
programme in vivo avec le centre
jeunesse de lanaudière maintenant
appeler le centre intégré de santé et
services sociaux
c'est vraiment un programme
d'entraînement a développé une nouvelle
compétence pour faire face à des
situations stressantes sens d'une
situations de la vie courante comme
roxanne a été prise en charge par la dpj
vous ne verrez pas son visage mais
puisque une caméra a été fixé sur sa
tête ses deux son point de vue que nous
vivons l'expérience ap lecteurs
respiration dundar lorsqu'on se dresse
un individu on voit ses traits
tempérament tôt à paraître dans le cas
de leurs cendres
ça c'est une jeune fille du père
manifester de l'anxiété mais ça va aussi
se manifester par des comportements plus
activé ou agressés ou
de colère l'entraîneur aide roxane à
reconnaître les signes de stress et
surtout à trouver la bonne stratégie
pour y faire face
l'espagne et j'aurai besoin des dons
petit enlever un costume de stratégie du
prend présentement je demande de l'aide
le club de jean lève je le demandais de
l'aïe dont le vus avec roczen
aujourd'hui devant des bâtisses une
stratégie stratégie favorable mais
certains jeunes vont utiliser les
stratégies de repli sur soi je ne
s'affirme auront pas donc là ça peut
mener dans la vie réelle dans la vie
réelle à prévenir des problèmes si je
m'affirme pas si je prends garde de le
dire à quelqu'un non j'aime pas ça parce
que ça ça change la perception par
rapport au stress c'est sûr que ma
perception a changé parce que dans le
fond mais j'avais une spirale négative
dans le fond je nourrissais moi même mon
entreprise presse donc qui prenait de
l'ampleur mais c'est ça que ça l'aide à
trouver des moyens afin de les gérer des
clubs ça travailleuse sociale estime que
roxanne aujourd'hui beaucoup mieux ses
émotions avec capables de rationaliser
avant c'était juste des motifs les
capable de comprendre d'où la situation
vient donc son copain en fait telle
chose c'est nous l'a bouleversée et cap
atlantique une stratégie maintenant pour
faire face et trouver une solution
bon ok rockson on est rendu à l escalade
présentement t as combien sur ton 15 aux
fréquences mec ça 25 125 au repos tu es
à combien 52
les prêts roxane est habituée de faire
de l'escaladé lem soit des bonnes
compétences de hausser la demande de
hausse il défie pour roxane pour ce prix
d'aujourd'hui
c'était tout simplement de lui donner
l'occasion d'avoir un petit peu plus de
mal à l'aise pour voir apparaître
simplement cessé de stress pour qu'elles
soient en mesure de mieux s'adapter
même si le défi est plus grand pour
partir de maintenant doit seulement
ouvert problème ouais je puisse mettre
mon fils sur le blue jackets cela celui
à gauche en vue là bas on sait que de
bien gérer le stress est un facteur
protecteur pour la santé mentale et j'ai
changé de comportement qu'il ya une
logique théorique derrière le programme
mais maintenant on se rend compte qu'on
développe d'autres choses aussi qu'on
travaille l'affirmation de soi est pas
quelque chose qui était prévu au départ
le programme in vivo a été déployé dans
trois centres jeunesse et trois
commissions scolaires en plus d'être
pratiquée en france
le fait qu'on ait percé en france pour
nous c'est encourageant ça montre que ça
répond à un besoin d'intervention
autant pour les institutions pour les
intervenants pour les adolescents une
façon à la fois ludique et concrète pour
aider les jeunes à faire face au stress
bravo bravo ici vincent maisonneuve
radio-canada joliette est dit fier de
toi ouais accéder